[Music]
welcome my name is jules van binsbergen
and i'm the nip on life professor in
finance at the wharton school of the
university of pennsylvania and i'm
jonathan burke the ap giannini professor
finance at the graduate school of
business at stanford university welcome
to the first episode of our podcast
series all else equal the series is
about making good business decisions
we will talk about how to do it
and why it's so important but of course
making good business decisions is very
similar to making good decisions in
general and so we hope the principles we
learn on this podcast series will apply
in your personal life as well
making good decisions is a very old
problem
and a major breakthrough on how to do it
properly occurred during the
enlightenment with the discovery of the
scientific method
the scientific method has become so
ingrained that it's hard to imagine a
world without it
many people would regard it simply as
obvious
of course major breakthroughs are often
obvious once they're made but
discovering them is an entirely
different matter
the basis of this podcast series is that
good business decision making is very
much like applying the scientific method
so what is the scientific method
in a nutshell the scientific method is
evidence-based decision making and the
main insight of the scientific method
is that you need evidence to support
your theory in fact
unless a theory is supportable by
evidence what scientists call testable
it isn't really a theory
scientists don't waste time and effort
on theories that are untestable one
other thing that is important from the
business perspective is that we would
like to reject theories and we would
like to reject ideas as quickly as
possible and the reason why it is
important as a business decision to try
to do this is that we don't want to
waste resources on things that don't
work
and so it's important that we organize
our organizations in such a way that you
give people the opportunity to go after
things and try to reject them now here
is the issue
for most people it feels much better to
be proven right than it feels to be
proven wrong now it's hard to say why
that is because you could say if you're
proven wrong you've learned something
new and shouldn't learning something new
make you feel good
for some reason for most people it
doesn't work that way it feels that if
you're proven wrong that you've lost
something and so for that reason we need
to set up rules and we need to set up a
system which is really what the
scientific method did so that we can
together try to overcome that flaw so in
group decision making and making
decisions together we would like to set
up things in such a way that this human
flaw of not wanting to admit your
mistakes and sticking to your guns is
overcome so that we together can move
forward
it reminds me of an anecdote attributed
to alfred sloan the legendary ceo of
general motors
he was chairing a board meeting where a
major decision was being made
and he turned around and asked for
dissent on the decision and nobody
dissented when that happened he decided
to table the decision and he said to
everybody we cannot make a decision of
this magnitude without dissent
and the key there is
if you don't try you can't falsify so a
common mistake for people to make is
they don't try
this is a very common mistake in
business organizations you know as the
famous physicist richard feynman once
said
the first principle is you must not fool
yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
and in many organizations it's even
worse than that it is that the
organization sometimes or maybe even
often is set up that
falsifying things is punished
if you prove something or somebody wrong
particularly somebody that is higher up
in the organization it doesn't often
lead to big career successes and so one
way of improving organizational
structures is to make sure that if an
important idea is convincingly falsified
that the people who falsify it are being
rewarded for that
now one way to institutionalize things
is to set up explicitly what's called
red teams in blue teams where you
intentionally assign people on opposite
sides of an argument so that you try to
get all the pros and cons of the
decision out in the open so that
everybody can hear about them and trade
them off accordingly you know in science
one of the best examples of the cost of
trying not to falsify or worse having an
organization that punishes people for
dissent that punishes people for
falsifying is galileo
before galileo's time the center of the
renaissance the center of the
enlightenment was in italy and then
galileo came around with hard evidence
that the
universe does not revolve around the
earth
rather than look at that evidence what
the church did was shut him down and in
shutting him down and punishing him
wasn't just he they shut him down they
punished him
they sent this clear message that they
were not in the falsifiable business and
the net result was that the
enlightenment moved to northern europe
outside the purview of the catholic
church and so
all major breakthroughs
previously was in italy and after that
it was not in italy again so the cost to
the intellectual environment in italy
was enormous now and so the
enlightenment values really stress to
believe that science and logic give
individuals more knowledge and
understanding than tradition or feelings
and so in that sense it's closely
related to rationalism
so now if you wanted to get some sense
of how successful the scientific method
has been
it is no coincidence that if you go back
for as long as we have decent data and
economic growth that say between 1300
and 1800 we had a 500 year spell of
almost no economic growth and then in
1800 suddenly there was this explosion
of economic growth it was almost like a
miracle and it's not a coincidence that
that moment of economic growth arising
coincides with the introduction of the
scientific method through enlightenment
values
you know jules i think it's hard not to
argue that google isn't the most
successful uh organization of our time
and i think looking from the outside
that that success is very largely driven
by the fact that they adopt these
principles that they have a single focus
on evidence-based decision-making and
essentially applying the scientific
method to making business decisions so
we are really happy
to have on our show
the chief financial officer
of alphabet the parent company of google
ruth porat
ruth
welcome to our show
i am delighted to be with you thanks for
having me
ruth we are so excited that you're with
us today so let me start by setting the
stage a bit right now your company's
stock market capitalization is close to
two trillion dollars with cash holdings
close to 140 billion dollars just in
2020 you made 12 billion dollars in
investments in planned property and
equipment and you've also done some
major acquisitions in the past few years
one example is fitbit which you acquired
for over two billion dollars these types
of investment decisions are only a small
subset of the business decisions that
you need to make on a regular basis so
that really brings us to the main theme
of this podcast which is how do you make
good business decisions and i don't
think we could think of a better guess
to kick the podcast off with so let me
pose this question directly to you how
does google make major business
decisions and what process do you follow
maybe you could also comment a bit on
what you would say as google's biggest
strength in this well i would say one of
the
core processes at google that i greatly
admire is what we call the okr process
on an annual basis
every product area every function and
then rolling up at the corporate level
we set objectives the o
and establish key results the kr
and that becomes a heavily discussed
debated sort of strategic set the set
the priorities for the upcoming year and
the goal with okrs is one that they're
audacious enough so that
by the end of the year you achieve about
two-thirds of them the goal is not to
achieve 100 the view is if you achieve
100 you have not set the goals high
enough and then have very specific
metrics that you where you can measure
your progress along the way and there's
quite a bit of debate and discussion to
set what is that strategic roadmap and
then to roll it up so that there's a
true north for the whole company and
there's a shared point of view about
what we're doing that's the starting
point
it sounds to me that this process is
also very data analytical process so
that raises the question how important
is data to you and how do you deal with
people that would say things like i
think that decision making should be
done at the gut level if it feels right
to me i want to go for it regardless of
what the data says how do you respond
when people say that well you've hit a
couple of points that i think are most
important you know i i've said so often
anchor everything in data and the rest
will fall you absolutely need to have
the truth that comes from the data in
the analytics i think the biggest
mistake is when people think that
because they've done it before and it
worked they can operate on gut and
frankly i would say if you're concerned
about taking the time to do the data and
analytics why it should be reinforcing
to a decision and in fact through the
okr process and frankly everything that
we do it helps lay out what is that
roadmap what are the metrics and
milestones along the way where you can
gauge whether you're making the progress
that you expected and if you aren't
maybe the reason is you need to invest
more maybe the reason is that the idea
wasn't as
audacious or well thought out as needed
but data are sort of the arbiter of
truth and so a critically important i
would say the the other elements of your
question that's really important is when
you're thinking about what are the
metrics
what data do you want
you need to you know that that doesn't
that is not always as obvious as it
seems you need to make sure that the
metrics that are being
selected are ones that are driving the
outcome that um that is desired and i
think we can all think about companies
over the you know over history who've
selected the wrong metrics and set the
wrong north star so that data and the
choice of metrics is key
so ruth speaking as a professor
often people don't like what the data
says
they come in with emotions
they come in with a set way of doing
things
the data says something different and
they ignore the data
how do you deal with that
well
again i think one of the really
important elements in data and analytics
is to
look at
the trends that come through the data i
think that what you don't want is a
false precision i often say i don't like
the numbers i like the trends and i like
the sensitivity analysis because i think
it is
too easy to anchor on on just a set of
numbers that in my view is not helpful
the most important is to look at what
are the trends over time
and then to your question
break it down to the sensitivity
analysis what are the key variables that
will drive behavior one way or another
are outcomes what must you believe
and when you lay out in my view
the sensitivity analysis and you engage
in a discussion
about the variables that will drive it
it makes for a more constructive process
coming with just a kind of flat set of
data isn't constructed because obviously
the world in which we live is not static
and so there may be some validity in the
point that there's concern about what a
flat set of data tells you and hence the
importance in sensitivity analysis and
engaging your business partner your
colleagues with what do you disagree
and why
and then trying to break down those
elements of it but to me the sensitivity
analysis is one of the key
tools that we all use
very nice
so one other big theme that we want to
address in this podcast is what are the
most common mistakes that people make
when making decisions
what do you think those mistakes are and
what can you do about them
well you've both already hit on the
biggest mistake and i most certainly saw
it as a banker and that's when people
decide that they can go on instinct or
their gut as opposed to data and
analytics and as i've already said that
really does not happen with any
frequency
at google i think the other critical
element
is an over reliance on what i've
described as sort of like flat data not
looking at the dynamic nature of the
world in which we operate and that's the
value of sensitivity analysis but it's
also the importance of understanding
when you're living in a very competitive
market as we do that any action we take
is going to lead to change in that
overall ecosystem and trying to think
through
how the world will continue to evolve
and so sort of living in a silo
living in a cave and not understanding
the dynamic nature of what one does i
think is a key area and then i think the
third and it goes to the importance of
setting out goals up front and having
clear metrics and milestones against
which you measure your performance you
have to have a way to check along the
way whether things are working and you
have to admit um when it's not and i
would say that if you don't have things
that fail you're either not reaching
high enough or you're not being honest
enough with yourself that you're not
doing as well as you expected and so
there's a a whole protocol at google
around what's called blameless
postmortems it's the goal to actually do
a route analysis at the end of something
that hasn't gone as well as you want
not blaming anyone
assuming that process actually can lead
to bad outcomes people have good intent
but you need the right process so what
is it that we can learn through a
blameless post-mortem
such that next time you're in a similar
situation you actually have a better
you know better outcome and i'm very
much of the view that one of the most
valuable things each of us brings is
pattern recognition from some of the
toughest things that we've ever gone
through but you need to take the time to
deconstruct what did i learn
what pattern recognition is important so
that it sets you up better for the next
time
you know this is an important theme in
this podcast series it's very important
that you admit your mistakes
and so why is that so hard to do when
obviously you learn the most from when
you make a mistake i mean in principle
it should be easy to admit you make a
mistake so in that vein
what mistakes have you made yourself
that you particularly watch out for what
are you most careful about not doing
i'd like to actually comment on the
first part and then i will come to the
second part you're absolutely right that
human nature is it can be hard even when
you're trying to make it safe to say
something went wrong
and um probably one of the the
best approaches i've seen is at x our
moonshot factory where
they actually celebrate
when they're deprecating something
because they want to make it safe to say
i tried i reached it didn't work and if
you don't celebrate and say i learned
something from it it's going to make it
hard for people to raise their hands i
created something in finance similarly i
call it the super duck award which is i
want people to raise their hands early
when something's not working
because my view is that when we bring
people together
we can solve problems and time is the
one thing you can never get back and so
you have to find ways to actually make
it fun and safe to say
something seems like it's not going as
well as expected so i do think that's a
critical area
to your question where have i found that
um i keep coming back to it
you know i i would say probably
the most important thing as leaders is
we need to have the right organizational
structure and the right people
yes absolutely and and there was
something earlier that you said that i
also thought was very interesting
because one thing that we wanted to push
as an idea is that good business
decision making is very much like the
scientific method so quickly finding out
what doesn't work so that everybody can
move forward is very valuable we don't
want to spend time on hypotheses that
have already been proven wrong even when
people just want to stick with them it's
just a waste of time exactly as you said
the time that we will never get back and
so ruth i have one more question for you
that i would like to have your thoughts
on so sometimes people argue with
important decisions that they want to
have a red team and a blue team where
you intentionally assign people to take
opposing positions have you ever tried
this do you think that this is something
that would work well under what
conditions do you think it will work
well and when do you think it would not
work very well
i actually use that quite often i think
it's a great idea
you know i think that um when business
leaders are putting forth the proposal
they're not putting it forth because
they think it's a bad idea i think it's
a good idea so what i want to hear is
that what can go wrong or why would i
not do this
how much consensus was there on the idea
what were the voices that were actually
uh questioning it and i think there are
multiple ways to get at that kind of
debate there are plenty of times where
i'll say i want somebody to take the
alternate view
walk me through it why would i not do
this
but i would say that at an even more
basic level in meetings i think it's
extremely valuable i think a best
practice is
when you're soliciting abuse around the
room first of all have a diverse team
because you'll get a diversity of views
and it's one of the most potent elements
of
looking at how to actually grow as a
team second is start with the most
junior people in the room you want to
make sure you're hearing the voices of
the most junior people in the room
they're probably the ones who who are
most kind of granular in the data having
done the analysis
and it can be hard for a junior person
to say i actually am concerned about x y
or z when all the senior people have
already said this is fantastic so i
think there's a process about how you
run the discussion
um and then i do think at times the red
team blue team red team white team
whatever you want to call it uh is is
super helpful
so it's it's there's a lot of elements
and process that i think can enhance the
quality of the debate and the insight
so ruth what i'm hearing from you is
that at google
you've selected for people who
appreciate the importance of not being
in a set mindset
understand that you can be wrong
and maybe you've done something one way
and there's might be a better way
that's not the average person
how do you maintain this culture
at google
i believe there's a culture of humility
people feel we're never doing enough
and sometimes that can be
kind of wearing because there's always a
sense of you're not doing that but in my
career
what i have seen time and time again is
humility drives people to actually raise
the bar on themselves and on everything
they're doing because they are their
concern is we're not doing enough
and i saw it with the best bankers i see
it at google all the time
it we should be able to do more we
should explore more there are different
things that we can be doing i think the
key in my career that i've seen
is that the single best predictor
for failure is hubris
and it goes to so many of the things
that the two of you have been asking
which is if you want to default to gut
you want to default to instinct you're
so smart you can throw out all the data
you don't want to engage in the debate
that's when you need to get concerned
because if in fact you approach things
with intellectual curiosity
and humility
and it's about learning so that you can
do even better you're going to want
every tool at your disposal and you're
going to want to be surrounded by people
who challenge you
and so i think at the core of it
it is about who are we individually and
how do we as leaders
pull together a group that you know
where you create the psychological
safety to have a debate admit you don't
know
but intellectual curiosity and humility
to me are
absolutely
critical
if you want to build a successful high
performance team
i couldn't agree more the idea of
humility understand that you might not
know the answer
that you always need to learn is so
important
it's one of the reasons jules and i were
motivated to create this podcast series
yeah
well
to to acknowledge to be in a leadership
position say i don't know for many
people is hard i actually think it
that level of openness and vulnerability
actually builds stronger teams your
teams want to know that their voice is
wanted
i often tell people we don't hire super
talented people
and
not want to hear what they say the
reason you're at the table is we want to
know what you think
and so i think that you know the leader
knows everything isn't going to get the
best out of their team and they're not
going to have the best results
thank you so much ruth this was just
great we really appreciate the
opportunity to talk with you today
it's been a pleasure talking to you
thank you so much for filing the time
and sharing your insights with us thank
you thank you it's wonderful to see you
both of you i look forward to uh staying
in touch and seeing where you go with
this take care
wow that was such a great interview and
she had so many good points to make also
related to the things that we talk about
our students in class all the time
ultimately this is what this podcast is
going to be all about
smart thinking concrete examples and
great guests but more particularly it's
going to be about making mistakes
identifying those mistakes and
understanding why those mistakes were
made to begin with because that allows
us to learn from those mistakes but the
key insight is unless you're willing to
admit you've made a mistake in the first
place we can't even begin the process of
learning from my mistakes and i think
today we saw the importance
of a
admitting that we make mistakes but b
understanding that that is a difficult
process to do and then
going through that process
in fact i would say another way around
the only way of becoming a better
business decision maker is to be willing
to go through that process
so in our next episode we're going to
explore a very important mistake that
many people make and in the process we
will also explain why we decided to call
this podcast all else equal
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at apple podcasts we love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
next episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcasts for more information and
episodes visit all elseequalpodcast.com
or follow us on linkedin the old sql
podcast is a joint venture of stanford
university's graduate school of business
and the wharton school at the university
of pennsylvania and is produced by
podium podcast co
[Music]
you